speaking of older dudes do you know who
i ran into this morning
uh blue jam michael jai white
oh dude spawn dude jack deal
that's a big man insane i don't know how
old he is
but he's moving he's closing out my age
yeah i did i said because i i geek out
over that dude i love you
or what
uh just real quick over spawn or
what like why why would you geek out
over him all those strongest martial art
films he's done yep
take that
by the way here's the thing about me i
geek out over martial
martial art films it doesn't matter like
if they're like low budget
good i don't like that i'm just stopping
he's worked with kimbo michael j white
is the real [ __ ] deal real deal and
i'm saying this as well and
i don't give a [ __ ] what anybody says
you put that guy in the cage now
right [ __ ] now does he beat herschel
walker
no no no i'm not giving it down wait you
don't think he'll be herself
walker trains first of all let me excuse
me excuse me i know you've seen never
back down or whatever but
um walker fought and strike for it's not
a real competition mike
michael jack white but you don't think
michael j white can do that he's a big
athletic strong guy who studies martial
arts
he does he'll teach you how to jab he
was showing these guys where they pull
back he's like just go straight
that's all good all good the problem is
he's never actually i don't believe and
you might be wrong i might be wrong
please correct me
he's never actually gotten into a cage
or a ring and actually fought
that is significant it's like when you
say those dudes are false advertisement
i'm saying there's a big difference
between people that make the walk
getting a ring in a cage
train for that specifically and fight in
an mma bout like herschel walker
who's also a who's also a he also
trained he also trained at aka
yeah with some sam but he probably
fought in competitions i don't think
michael j
white i might be wrong maybe maybe
karate or taekwondo
taekwondo competitions and now you're
ready this might hurt your feelings
those don't count
they don't count this now this might
hurt daddy those don't count no that
doesn't hurt my feelings
okay i'm very aware of that the way
you're aware of it now if i i'll kill
you with my feet if i have to
okay wait what does this say he's
competed in a he's competing he's never
has never that's a has never before at
least yeah
but doesn't mean he doesn't know like
some fundamentals or like you know he's
been a martial artist which is cool
it also doesn't mean that he's not a
very physically
specialist have you ever seen john cloud
van damme when he saw the diaz brothers
outside gold's gym and then was
teach him a technique to do inside the
octagon no that hurts my feelings
i saw that too why why well explain
that's no different than vin diesel
coming up to [ __ ] france and got him
like hey
you know and they do it
through they grew up they grew but shut
the [ __ ] up
and they do it all the time it happens
do they really they do it all the time
were the diaz brothers listening yeah
they were cool because they're nice
guys and it's also jean-claude van damme
so you can entertain it then when they
get on their car they're like what the
[ __ ] man
really they're not gonna use it so okay
so a lot of the dudes that do the acting
uh and the martial art films you're just
saying they're not legit fighters
no what about bruce lee and jet lake no
the answer is absolutely
he was an acrobatic actor he's never
fought he was a he's a businessman and
carried the torch from martial arts and
did wonderful things but as far as
like actual fighting he did do he did do
an arm bar
and a legit arm bart and enter the
dragon
it's pretty cool that was a japanese
jiu-jitsu arm bar there's a he says
did you see once a time in uh um
in hollywood well there's that movie but
did you you know
uh when brad pitt froze them you know uh
gene labelle really did that to bruce
lee
that's where that story comes from
that's not a fake story i did remember
jean labelle actually hemmed up bruce
lee and
beat the [ __ ] out i do that's the room
bruce lee was five
seven one twenty he's a pioneer though
he's not hitting him
he's tiny he was tiny jean labelle's a
gorilla gina bell
is a guerrilla and was a judoka guy and
a wrestler and a hardcore
joke yeah and and i have you know and so
unless
so you're saying basically you're saying
unless you've like competed
in that world you don't it's not that
michael jai white isn't a real athlete
probably and has in very strong and very
you know physically you look at him and
he's big and
posing i'd rather see rogan versus him
in a fight
something like that something like that
makes more sense really but i mean when
you say michael j
white if you're if you compare him to
professionals
professionals who do it for a living
it's just a different thing
it's like you taking tips when you do
sets for me in houston
from your funny uncle at the barbecue
you're like have you ever done stem like
nah yeah but he's hilarious though dude
he's been funny forever like okay
i guess i'll listen to him it's like
when you so so when you're strong
physically big guy but you when you
first tried the bench
i mean it's a bad example but another
another good example is this like
you see guys you guys see but it is but
it is similar though
if you if you watch guys hit mitts you
can get really good at hitting knits
like really good you can look awesome
yeah i mean you can pop pop up and look
amazing and move around and stuff like
that
the difference between that and getting
in a ring with a guy who's hitting you
and learning distance and patterns it's
not even
in the same conversation but i was
watching this video of him explaining
things to kimbo slice
no but he must but you gotta watch i
mean if you watch the video would
it's not that he wouldn't but wait wait
it's not it's not don't
it's not that michael j white can't go
can't go
you know because he saw maybe he took a
boxing but he understands boxing that
you know
he says with your boxing go straight
from here as opposed to here
okay that's how quick he was
oh it's not that he can't give advice in
that sense like in a vacuum
but i'll but he shouldn't and i love
mikey
what he shouldn't he should have no
different than somebody never doing
stand-up
going up to you giving you a tag for
your closing joke
you'd be like oh that's interesting that
he has the
all right it's just yeah it's just you
know you're just not
in that pool you're just crazy i i i
didn't know okay
especially but if you're saying that to
a guy who does it for a living
the assumption is that they don't know
that that they haven't trained in that
right yeah so so we were doing fighting
we were doing firing kids 3d and brandon
and i were doing sprints
watch out quickies
just move it out the way all right so
yeah now notice the speed of the first
two right ready yeah
that's one two okay now here's the third
one
don't let me hit it ready
you think that's fighting chappelle he's
awesome
i think he was only trying to help kimbo
they're like legit being like dude maybe
try this out yeah oh maybe just for the
movie
i don't know it's more i don't know i
don't know what the context is well that
was the uh well i know michael j white
and i know he's a really good person it
was a fight scene
uh they had in that movie and kimbo like
they were playing like uh
guys in prison and you know michael jai
white fought like seven dudes pretty
much and
kicked their ass so when you do when you
do something i know about is
combat on film the one thing you never
want to do
on film comment is actually do real
fighting yeah you want to exaggerate
your punches
you want the martial arts stuff so guys
who really fight would look terrible on
film because it's two
my friend west chatham was doing a movie
with uh sylvester stallone
okay i forget which movie and wes trains
boxing like he's that wild card all the
time
so he was like oh i know boxing is
perfect for me so they're in a fight
scene with sylvester and his hands are
up he's got this
inspector goes cut he goes dude what are
you doing
he's like what like i train boxing he's
like this isn't
real fighting yeah he's like i want you
to throw he's like go against all your
instincts i want you to throw from
the ground and make it real dramatic and
loose
he's like so those straight punches like
that technique this isn't the space and
you know when you when you translate so
what we we did firing kits we were
sprinting
and i i studied when high school i was
on track because i threw the javelin and
i
and i i did i said i and i high school
and i did uh
i did and i did uh uh polvo because
nobody else would right
yeah like seven feet